how are you packed well rich thank you
very much for having me set up the table
for you is LSU your number one team if
you were ranking them yourself yeah
based on resume yes because they played
the best schedule and they're undefeated
based on test it's kind of hard to go
against Ohio State has been incredible
in every phase of the game so I would
say those who have daylight on everyone
else at this point I know you know
Alabama and Clemson are still where they
are based on who they can and I think
you know there are some very good teams
but right now LSU and Ohio State has a
business I think damn with Ohio State on
pardon me sorry the Ohio State with the
Ohio State University and we're talking
about obviously what Zeke looks like in
the NFL and Michael Thomas what he looks
like in the NFL with the Saints I mean
you could make the case that they're the
top running back and wide receiver in
the NFL right now what nick Bosa is
doing in in this level over the first
eight weeks has been Defensive Player of
the Year worthy and now we're watching
chase young wreck everything at the
collegiate level would you put him you
know Heisman Trophy race right now
Pat sure yeah I mean he's the best
player on that team
adjust the field has been great JK Davis
great but he has been the best player
and I mean he's just annihilating teams
I mean what he did to Wisconsin was one
of the more dominant defensive
performances I've seen you know watching
him and like I've been trying to come up
with a comp right he's thicker in the
lower body and longer than Von Miller so
he's almost more like Julius Peppers I
think you know in terms of Jimmy six six
and he's fast but he's got he's got the
the base to to be able to withstand
blocking to you know I mean he is he's a
beast if if you don't need a quarterback
I would think you're taking chase young
first in the draft yeah I know
ginormous is the only word I would use I
mean he just Julius Peppers is an
interesting comp Pat it's fascinating
because you don't think of of of
somebody Julius Peppers sighs doing the
stuff
that we're seeing young-do he does look
like he's got von miller game in Julius
Peppers body your that's a really good
point
yeah I mean he's he's just something you
could say comin last year you know and
they were raving about him at Ohio State
and now he has taken it up the
appropriate next level you know he's the
next great pastor yeah after the the
brothers bolsa and several others they
put out there to Ohio State Pat forty of
Yahoo Sports joining me here on the Rich
Eisen show let's get to LSU and I mean
they're using a former Ohio State
quarterback in Jobar Oh being number one
right now how do you think they match up
against Alabama since obviously we're
looking over the steering wheel at their
next game here yeah both of them have an
off date so yeah that we can go ahead
and look ahead and I mean I think they
match up really well I think so far
they've been the better team and
especially if if two is you know it all
compromise coming back from the ankle
situation so you know I'm just I've been
dazzled by the transformation of LSU
you know they they were always very
talented and extremely boring you know
because they were just so mediocre and
vanila offensively and now take our
aerial circus throwing all over great
wide receivers exciting quarterback I
mean they are just a totally different
team to watch and it's going to be a
really fun matchup if you remember in
2011 number one number two LSU Alabama
that was a nine six game mr. B forty
nine forty it could be an absolute
shootout that would be amazing I for
sure and borrow obviously a Heisman
candidate right now for LSU and this
team in him versus two it would be
fascinating what are you hearing about
to his ankle as we're currently sitting
here right now all the talk is positive
confident he's going to be fine you know
we'll see how it actually works out he
had a similar procedure done to the
other ankle last year on December 1st he
played on December 29th in the playoff
game against Oklahoma and he was very
good I'm not sure he was 100% and that
was four weeks this is a three week
turnaround so you're asking more from
him from that standpoint
and I think they'll need more from him
they probably need it Matt game so you
know I think it's a lot to ask but you
know they're saying all the right things
so far coming out of Tuscaloosa
so you mentioned Oklahoma let's get to
it right now how stunning was that loss
for you oh absolutely shocking
I mean they've just been playing so well
you know handling everything that came
at him that I did not see that coming
but you know it's that time of year
third straight week we have had an
undefeated top ten team lose to an
unranked opponent
it was South Carolina over Georgia it
was Illinois Wisconsin and now Oklahoma
takes a hit and you know what it showed
to me is that their defense hadn't been
fully fixed there have been major
improvement from the year before but
that was a big backslide to give up 48
points to Kansas State so does that cost
him the a college football playoff spot
Pat there's only four home and I think
there should be because we're sitting
here right now I mean let's get into it
right here right now
as we're sitting here right now LSU and
Alabama where you assume is going to
play a competitive game that that will
leave even the loser
worthy of a playoff spot should the SEC
championship game not take care of the
the winner of the game then you've got
Ohio State we'll get to my alma mater in
a moment to see how that might stack up
in late November Clemson we all see the
competition that's coming their way I
mean how does Alabama crack I mean how
does Oklahoma crack that top four pad I
don't think they do I mean they're up
against it the you know the problems are
you know the rest of the league is
pretty uninspiring so you know what
looked like a big win over Texas well
you know Texas just lost to TCU
there there big non-conference win was
over UCLA well we know UCLA enacted so
the the resume it's going to be hard to
stack that up and say that it compares
to anybody from the Big Ten or the SEC
and then yeah Clemson sitting there 13
and OH as the defending champions you
know they're going so I you know I I
think that they're in a difficult spot
here that was saying that was a very
damaging loss for Oklahoma
pad 40 Yahoo Sports here on
Rich Eisen show and let's get into
Lincoln Riley Pat because again to bring
up the NFL you've got an open job in DC
where they drafted a 50 touchdown
thrower from Ohio State just last year
they need a coach to take that kid to
the next level you've got a team in
Cleveland that has Mayfield's Baker
Mayfield at at at their helm right there
Lincoln's former player you also have a
Cowboys team that has their coach on a
prove-it deal you've got a Jets team
that's got only one win with somebody
like Sam Darnell what I'm driving at is
there are a host of NFL teams that would
love to take their young quarterback or
their situation and hand it to somebody
with so much buzz about him he's lincoln
Raleigh possible to go to the NFL as
we're currently sitting here right now
listen doesn't thing I mean you know
that for all the reasons you just
enunciated there's gonna be teams that
want him there's gonna be situations
where he would have you know the kind of
guy to work with that he has done great
work already and I mean if you want to
you know I grew up in no suit Texas I
bet he wouldn't mind talking to Cowboys
you know if that one opens up so you
know I I think you have to listen does
he want to go I don't know you know
there's a loss like that make him say
look into that gosh you know it here in
the big 12 we lose one game and our
season could be ruined I you know I
don't know but he's a great fit in
college but he could be very good i NFL
coach I think as well just because this
year offensive acumen and quarterback
wizardry honey meat he fits what that
league wants right now and do you think
he would obviously just listen anything
that you might hear though going on at
Oklahoma or the fact that you know there
might not be another quarterback
currently in the pipeline that he could
turn into a Heisman Trophy came to be
anything of that nature that might add
some fuel to this fire that no doubt I
think is coming figuratively to the NFL
yeah you know I mean they look they've
got the next five star they're on campus
the wonderfully named evocative
answer rattler you know sitting there
waiting in the wings who knows there may
be a you know another grad transfer
that's out there saying yeah I can't
wait to go try to spend a year with
Linkin Riley I you know so he's
definitely not going to be hurting for
talent to coach at Oklahoma and you know
if you look at it objectively he should
have the best team in the big 12 since
Texas can't get out of its own way for
the foreseeable future and so you know
he's got a good thing right now but
again is you if you're trying to win
national championships does he look and
say that the conference could be a bit
of an impediment a bit of a sealing or
do you say if we go 30 nano and take
care of our business we'll be fine
or do you say I now want to try the NFL
I want to try that level you know so
it's it's really kind of I think just
gonna be kind of what moves him but the
opportunities are likely to be there and
then my final moments with you pat forty
am a moment for me if you don't mind
Michigan just destroying Notre Dame I
mean just absolutely spanking him why
why 14 more years what where did the
hell did that come from I thought that
was a misprint when I saw it on the
bottom line that these two teams renew
their rivalry for 2032 and 2033 what is
the the genesis of that I don't know
I mean Michigan made it clear afterwards
with their cheeky but also insufferable
tweet you know that they made it clear
that this was Notre Dame's
decision basically and like you know hey
we're here we'll play or whatever so it
is a shame because it's a great rivalry
love seeing those two play and you know
now I'm intrigued whether Harbaugh is
what seemed like burst of grandiosity
coming out of halftime to maria taylor
at penn state about this is gonna be our
finest hour maybe was right I mean cuz
they played a great second half they're
there drop touchdown away from tying
that game and maybe running and then
they come out and just steamroll Notre
Dame I'm like whoa where is it have they
finally flipped the switch they're in
Ann Arbor well I mean in order to match
up with Ohio State they have to do far
better on the defensive side of the ball
when the crossing routes come and those
and those shallow crosses and that that
that clearly confounded Michigan or or
would that Michigan refused to get out
of their defensive set to try and adjust
to last November and obviously scoring
points would be crucial to uh I'm
wondering how you see it based on the
last couple weeks here yeah I mean I you
would still look and say Ohio State's
the better team and as you pointed out
what was you know the glaring mismatch
last year mind day undressed on Brown
and here to where the mismatches were
obvious you know it's just the speed and
I'm trying to cover man-to-man billing
across the middle and and out to the to
the to the wings and it's just I mean
they just toyed with them that way you
know different set of circumstances they
would be in Ann Arbor this year you know
it should be a closer game but you know
we'll see if Michigan can sustain what
they've showed for the last game and a
half if they can hey bring it on that
would be a lot of fun to see a
competitive compelling important
Michigan Ohio State game and what did
that loss tell you about Brian Kelly and
Notre Dame and what's going on with that
program you know I mean I saw him play
Louisville in person to begin the season
then I saw him against Georgia uh yeah
you know I they they're limited you know
they are they have their limitations
they they've recruited well enough to be
consistently good they haven't recruited
well enough to be elite and something's
wrong with being booked you know he just
hasn't played well this year he had big
games against new New Mexico and Bowling
Green big whoop
everyone else says he's been he's
struggled against so you know they've
got there's still a gap between nowhere
Notre Dame is where Notre Dame thinks of
itself being Pat appreciate the time
always enjoy reading your work and
hearing you whenever you appear on other
shows including this one obviously so
thanks the call will we'll chat
hopefully in short order my pleasure
thank you ready you got it that's Pat
forty of Yahoo Sports at Yahoo forty on
Twitter Ethel are de for more of the
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV for free on BR Live or
download
Rich Eisen show up